12 نوفمبر 1796 خلال
عهد الإمبراطور بولس الأول
كاتدرائية التجلي الفوجي
حصل على الاسم الفخري للكاتدرائية للجميع
شقة
من كاتدرائية التجلي
يأتي اسم التجلي
المربع الذي يقف عليه و
جائزة الكذب حارة الكنيسة
[موسيقى]
كاتدرائية تجلي المخلص
تم إنشاء سياج غير عادي وفقًا للمشروع
كانت مهندسة محطة فاسيلي
توقيت ليتزامن مع انتصار الروسي التركي
1828 29 ويتكون من
العديد من البنادق التي تم الاستيلاء عليها
يتم تصديرها من قلاع مختلفة
تم التبرع بهذه المدافع للمعبد من قبل
مرسوم نيكولاس الأول في أغسطس 1825
عام كان هناك حريق و 1
كاتدرائية التجلي واحترقنا
تمكنت منه من إخراج كل ما هو رئيسي
فقط الجدران بقيت مقدسة من الكاتدرائية
في عام 182529 تم ترميمه
رقص المهندس المعماري فاسيلي بأناقة
إمبراطورية
كان في هذا الشكل الذي جاء إليه الخاص
أيامنا
نرى قرود المكاك رئيس هذه الكاتدرائية
Archpriest نيكولاي بريندن واحد ونصف
يعني تبدأ خدمة الإلهي
الليتورجيا
[موسيقى]
قبل الثورة في كاتدرائية التجلي
تصرفت ضيقة الأفق
الجمعية الخيرية التي
حافظ على دار للأيتام في المصم
مقصف مدرسة لأطفال الجنود و
شقق مجانية منذ عام 1912 فيه
تصرف الأخوة الاعتدال و
العفة وليمة التجلي
الرب
الاسم الشائع سبا التفاح
يقع في 19 أغسطس حسب الجديد
تم ترتيب اسلوب المعبد
سوق الفاكهة التقليدي بعد
كاتدرائية ثورة أكتوبر 1917
ظلت نشطة في عام 1918
أصبح الرعية لافتات بندقية عسكرية
الجوائز
المخزنة في الكاتدرائية تم الاستيلاء عليها و
تم نقله إلى متحف المدفعية من عام 1950
هذا الهدف رباعي
مجموعات هيرميتاج أيضًا في عشرينيات القرن الماضي
تم الاستيلاء على العديد من الرموز القيمة
قصة مثيرة للاهتمام
وأثناء حصار لينينغراد في
تم بناء ملجأ من القنابل في الطابق السفلي من المعبد
لكل 500 شخص الذي ظهر فيه
مساعدة وأنت
في عام 1946 ثمانية وأربعين كان
ترميم الواجهات و
التصميمات الداخلية للمعبد
[موسيقى]